welcome to the man of Recaps this is the
complete Transformers recap before rise
of the beasts in the first Transformers
Shia LaBeouf is Sam whitwicky a normal
teenage boy whose dad's taking him out
to buy his first car he picks out this
old yellow Camaro that is more than
meets the eye now that Sam has a car
he's able to give a ride home to the hot
girl from school Michaela played by
Megan Fox whose role in this film caused
a generation of boys to hit puberty but
meanwhile the Earth is being invaded by
transforming vehicles that are alien
robots in Disguise turns out Sam's great
grandfather was an Explorer Archibald
with Wiki who went to the North Pole and
found one of these Transformers that
crashed here years ago it blasted his
glasses with important information and
now that Sam put them up on eBay the
Decepticons are coming after him but
luckily his new cars a Transformer 2
here to protect him his name is
Bumblebee and his voice thing's broken
so he can't talk but he communicates in
a fun way using clips from the radio now
bumblebee calls in his good Transformer
friends the Autobots their leader
transforms into the semi truck with the
blue and red Flames paint job it is
Optimus Prime he explains they're from
the planet Cybertron where there was a
big civil war between the good Autobots
and the evil Decepticons led by Megatron
they go back to Santos to get the
glasses before the Decepticons but now
they're interrupted by the government
it's the super secret sector 7 who
monitors alien life here led by the
funny guy agent Simmons they have
Megatron's frozen body as well as the
allspark that could instill life into
machines make new Transformers but oh no
they led the Decepticons right to it
they wake up Megatron who's in a real
bad mood and oh it's a big chase oh yeah
meanwhile half the movie followed
military guy and his Squad fighting
Decepticons in the desert another half
of the movie followed a CIA analyst
who's inexplicably an Australian model
she got help from her nerd friend who
was playing Dance Dance Revolution at
his grandma's house there's a lot going
on in these movies but it all comes
together for the final battle
Transformers transforming explosions
everywhere Michael Bay going nuts but
they gotta keep the all-spark away from
Megatron because he wants to use it to
turn the earth into new Cybertron so
while the Transformers are having their
big robot fight sandwich wikis running
around with the plot thing Optimus and
Megatron have their final fight but it
looks like Megatron's gonna win so
Optimus wants to put the all-spark in
his chest which will kill him but
destroy the cube but Sam's like uh what
if I shove the cube and Megatron's just
instead and that works destroys the cube
kills Megatron yeah good thinking kid so
the Earth is saved Sam and Michaela have
a sunset make out then Optimus Prime
gives an inspiring speech and it is the
iconic Linkin Park credit song number
two is Transformers Revenge of the
Fallen sandwich wikis going off to
college but in his pocket he finds a
little piece of the all-spark that
blasts his mind with alien info the
Decepticon steel another piece of the
all-spark and put Neil spark in
Megatron's chest killed him but putting
it in again brings him back to life
Michaela comes to visit Sam to find him
in a compromising position but it's even
worse than it looks cause it's a
Transformer so Megatron grabs him to get
the info in his head but his car
Bumblebee busts in to save him Optimus
Prime comes too but oh no it was a trap
they've outnumbered him and now Megatron
kills Optimus Prime turns out Megatron
has a boss another Prime called the
fallen and now with Optimus out of the
way he's able to come down to earth and
get his revenge so it is the Revenge of
the Fallen now the government is
anti-transformer so Sam gets help from
agent Simmons who was fired from sector
7 and is now working in a deli but he
still is the Transformer expert has info
that they've been here longer than we
thought they break into the air and
space museum to find this old
Transformer who somehow teleports them
to Egypt because all nine primes were
here in ancient times to hide the
special plot thing that don't know
disintegrates then a bunch of
construction Decepticons all merged
together into one giant sucky monster
because it turns out the pyramids built
by Transformers now military guy rolls
up with the Cavalry and it's a big final
fight in Egypt explosions everywhere CGI
transforming Sam's parents are here for
some reason while the Transformers have
their big robot battle Shia LaBeouf's
running around with the plot thing he
has a vision where the ancient primes
demon worthy so it undissolves the thing
and he shoves it into Optimus chest and
Optimus Prime is back to life but the
Fallen busts in and grabs it before
anyone can react and he's gonna turn on
the pyramid thing that would turn the
earth into new Cybertron but now Optimus
merges with old playing guy and gets
Wings flies up there blows it up kills
the Fallen the day is saved Megatron
retreats to fight another day Sam and
Michaela have a sunset make out then
Optimus Prime gives an inspiring speech
and the credits hit us with that other
Linkin Park song number three use
Transformers Dark of the Moon Sam when
Wiki is happily dating not Megan Fox yes
after everything Sam and Michaela went
through they write her off with one line
and Sam moved on immediately Sam starts
working for John Malkovich but his
co-worker Ken Jong accustomed in the
bathroom with Transformers conspiracy
theories the Decepticons are
assassinating people for some big
cover-up Sam tries to warn the
government but they're like get out of
here kid we got this covered the
Autobots have been working with the
government they got their own super
secret team but now they discover a link
to another historical event the moon
landing yeah Transformers and in that
crash ship is optimus's old boss they
bring him back to life it's Sentinel
Prime but Sam calls up his old friend
agent Simmons and together they discover
the Decepticon secret Sentinel Prime
switched sides oh he's a Decepticon now
he uses the teleporting things to open a
portal on the moon with a secret
Decepticon Army was waiting and it's a
full-on Invasion the Earth can't stop it
the Decepticons say the leave Earth
alone if the humans Exile the Autobots
so Optimus Prime says goodbye and oh no
the Autobots are immediately blown up
and of course the Decepticons lied now
without the Autobots to stand in their
way they're gonna teleport Cybertron
here and use Earth to rebuild it but now
what's this the Autobots are still alive
if you have they saw that coming and
fake their deaths so it's the final
battle in Chicago and it's a full hour
of insane CGI action explosions
everywhere I have no idea what's
happening military guy shows up with the
Cavalry they jump out the plane Wing
suits wow and while the Transformers
have their big robot fight Shia
LaBeouf's running around with the plot
thing and he's gotten really good at
running Sam's girlfriend's boss is the
bad guy working with the Decepticons so
Sam tracks him down breaks the thing and
Al shuts it off Cybertron destroyed
Optimus and Sentinel have their final
Prime fight and it looks like sentinel's
gonna win but Megatron doesn't like that
Sentinel would be his boss so he busts
in to take him out so it's the final
battle Megatron vs Optimus and Optimus
just fully kills him this time so the
world is saved Sam and this new girl
have a sunset make out and Optimus Prime
gives an epic speech as they blast us
with that other Linkin Park song number
four is Transformers age of Extinction
Shia LaBeouf left the movies too our new
main human is Mark Wahlberg his name is
Katie Yeager and he's an inventor which
his daughter points out is not a real
job but one day he's fixing up this old
truck and wouldn't you know it it's
Optimus Prime after Chicago the
government is very anti-transformer
there's a new secret task force led by
Kelsey Grammer who's hunting down all
Transformers Decepticon and Autobots so
pretty soon they track Optimus Down K
Yeager's house explodes they get a ride
out of there from his daughter's secret
boyfriend who even though they're in
Texas is inexplicably Irish Kate's funny
best friend is TJ Miller and on the way
out so he's exploded so Optimus groups
with our new cast of Autobots a samurai
a British gangster and a guy still
fighting in Vietnam elsewhere Stanley
Tucci's a tech CEO who's found the
transformium that Transformers are made
of and has learned how to control it
he's building new man-made Transformers
but they're using Megatron's old brains
so he's accidentally created new
Megatron now Bounty Hunter robot shows
up with a cannon for a face blows up
Optimus he's bringing him back to
Cybertron because the creators want him
but Katie Yeager and friends rescue
optimists on their way out to destroy
Chicago again but now they have a bigger
problem because the deal that guy made
with Kelsey Grammer was to give him a
seed to get lots of transformium
unfortunately using it would destroy the
planet and in fact it's happened once
before the meteor that killed the
dinosaurs turns out Transformers
Megatron of course wants this to happen
to turn Earth into new Cybertron he
wakes up all these man-made Transformers
and turns him into his new Decepticon
Army but Optimus gets some
reinforcements too from the really old
Transformers that torn into dinosaurs so
it's the Epic final battle Transformers
transforming explosions everywhere I
have no idea what's happening the
American Military doesn't show up
because this takes place in Hong Kong
while the Transformers have their big
robot fight it's up to our humans to run
around with the plot thing Megatron
retreats to fight another day Kelsey
Grammer does not though he gets exploded
but now Cannon face finally realizes
Optimus escaped but with help from
Bumblebee and Mark Wahlberg in the end
Optimus takes this guy out so once again
the Earth is saved kade's daughter and
boyfriend have a sunset make out an
Optimus Prime blast into space he's
gotta go back to Cybertron to find out
who this mysterious Creator is and as he
gives an epic speech the credits hit us
with not Lincoln Park but imagine
dragons which I guess is kind of close
number five is Transformers The Last
Knight the government again is very
anti-transformer so Katie agar is a
fugitive living in the junkyard with his
Autobot friends his daughter and her
boyfriend are not in this movie his new
Sidekicks are funny Science Guy and
Spunky orphan kid so the government's
hunting all Transformers down but K
Yeager's trying to save him he finds
this one who crashed here and gives him
a mysterious Medallion but now Megatron
busts in he wants that Medallion so they
have a big fight but it's interrupted by
a random Butler Transformer who flies
Kate Yeager over to England to meet with
Anthony Hopkins he's the last Living
member of the whitwickens the secret
society that knows about Transformers
yeah as we've seen basically every big
moment in human history has been
Transformers including mythology like
King Arthur Knights of the Round Table
yeah Transformers the hot girl in this
movie is Vivian Wembley professor of
King Arthur stuff Anthony Hopkins
kidnaps her too because she's the last
living descendant of Merlin and the only
one who can use his magic Transformer
staff long story short they steal a
submarine go to the bottom of the ocean
to find Merlin's tomb and get a staff
but who's this busting in it's Optimus
Prime acting like a villain here to take
that staff yeah he flew to Cybertron to
find his creator who turns out is this
witch robot quintessa that instantly
possessed him so it's up to bumblebee to
fight his friend Optimus and he
eventually unbrainwashes him when he
speaks with his real voice they don't
even explain how he can talk now which
is especially weird because they had a
whole scene earlier where they tried to
fix his voice and decided they couldn't
so Optimus is unbrainwashed but the
knights the round table Bots are still
attacking him because he stole the staff
so Mark Wahlberg's got to use his new
medallion the wow summon Excalibur and
just then Megatron busts in and steals
the staff before anyone can react he
gives it to quintessa whose evil master
plan is the same as it's always been she
brings Cybertron here and is gonna suck
up for its energy to rebuild it agent
Simmons comes back to explain why Earth
turns out Earth and Cybertron are
connected in fact Earth's real name is
Unicron so they go to Stonehenge which
was also built by Transformers and
Anthony Hopkins tries to 1v1 Megatron
which doesn't work he blows up so it's
the final battle on the pieces of
Cybertron explosions everywhere CGI
robots I have no idea what's going on
Military guy rolls up with the Cavalry
we keep cutting to Tony Hale who's a
scientist then Kaden Vivian have a
sunset make out while the Transformers
are doing their big robot battle and the
humans are running around to do the plot
thing Megatron retreats to fight another
day but bumblebee blasts quintessa so
Vivian gets the staff and the world is
saved once again except for like all the
places that got totally destroyed and
also there's these giant metal horns
that appeared and were never explained
and a mysterious woman is gonna do
something with them whoa It's quintessa
in this guy days and as Optimus Prime
gives an epic speech it's really
disappointing not even close to Lincoln
Park and that brings us to bumblebee
it's the spin-off prequel about how
Bumblebee came to Earth in the 1980s and
it is a totally different type of movie
less big action Blockbuster more Disney
Channel original so bumblebee was
fighting in the war on Cybertron when
Optimus was like yo you need to escape
to Earth to get a foothold there so
bumblebee first comes to Earth in the
1980s which contradicts what we learned
in the last night about how he fought in
World War II but soon a Decepticon
catches up with him interrogates him for
information but Bumblebee's not talking
and so as punishment this is where it
happens Aki destroys Bumblebee's voice
bumblebee does beat this guy but he's
badly damaged so he finds a nice yellow
ball gun shuts down our human in this
movie is Haley Steinfeld as Charlie
Watson whose character trait is she
really wants a car at the junkyard she
finds this old yellow Beetle takes it
home to fix it up and oh whoa my car's
an alien she and Bumblebee become fast
friends in fact she's the one who names
him Bumblebee and she's the one that
helps him figure out that he can talk
using the radio so they're cruising
around getting up to Shenanigans but
John Cena's the sector 7 agent here to
hunt him down and also a couple more
Decepticons are here to destroy the
world so in the end bumblebees having a
robot fight while Charlie's running
around doing the plot thing but what's
this Bumblebee's gonna drown luckily her
backstory is that she was like a really
good diver until her dad died now she
doesn't dive anymore but now she
overcomes her fear and Dives in there to
save his life although of course he's a
robot that doesn't breathe air and I
mean in the last movie he wrote a
submarine to the bottom of the ocean
anyway John Cena accepts that
Bumblebee's a good guy now but the
government's still gonna hunt him so
they have to say goodbye he finds a cool
old Camaro to be his new disguise to
eventually be found by Sam whitwicky so
there you have it the complete
Transformers recap before rise of the
beasts if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]